on Radio and on your smartphone this is
talk TV
[Music]
tonight on Piers Morgan uncensor
Cristiano Ronaldo finally answers all
his critics I'll give my take on the
explosive interview that's rocking the
sporting World Ronaldo says Manchester
United have betrayed him and the club
has made no progress in 13 years was he
right to speak out to me now I'll be
joined live by football legend Graham
sunes
also tonight peaceful protest or Royal
outrage or just a silly egg I'll talk to
the protester accused of throwing an egg
at the king
and the heartbreaking story of Molly
Russell the teenage girl is tragic
suicide but social media on trial her
father joins me live
[Music]
from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored
well good evening welcome to Piers
Morgan on sense that it's the world
exclusive interview that's got the whole
world talking and have a vested interest
because I'm the one that did it days
before the football World Cup football's
biggest ever star has rocked the
sporting World we're running it they're
talking about it you can see the entire
interview interview to Piers Morgan just
breaking in England an exclusive
interview between Pierce Morgan and
Cristiano Ronaldo she's done this huge
high-profile interview it's now gone
outside of sport football media outside
of sports media and now is in mainstream
news reports Cristiano Ronaldo who has
said he is being betrayed by his Club
the 37 year old's comments were made
during an interview with Piers Morgan
for talktv Ronaldo releases the intro to
a interview he has with Pierce Morgan
you got on there on Twitter and you
tweeted Ronaldo I don't respect the
manager Ronaldo who uh missed today
because of illness but has also done any
uh an interview with Piers Morgan Bill
Cristiano Ronaldo has accused Manchester
United of betraying him in an interview
there has been a huge reaction to this
interview before it's even gone to air
and here are some of the papers around
the world in fact from America we've had
Australia you've had uh of course all
around the UK Spain Italy I've had
messages on Twitter from everyone pretty
much uh because he is in the end he's
the biggest star that football's ever
seen Ronaldo has nearly half a billion
followers on Instagram think about that
he'll pass that total probably sometime
in the next week far ahead of any other
human being on the planet
you can see the entire interview we've
titled it 90 minutes for Cristiano
Ronaldo right here on Piers Morgan on
censored on Wednesday and Thursday night
it's a two-parter both shows starting at
eight o'clock it's one of the most
explosive interviews certainly that I've
ever done
tens of millions of people have already
viewed the two short clips we released
last night and there are more fireworks
coming later this evening because
Ronaldo speaks people listen he's not
just in my view the greatest footballer
of all time he's a global Mega star
he's of course highly paid too and he's
extremely commercially viable to any
club sales of his shirts at Manchester
United broke all records within 24 hours
of him going back
and after a year in which many people
including some of his ex-teammates have
blamed him for the decline at Manchester
United he simply decided he'd had enough
they're trying to force you out yes not
only the coach but the other two or
three guys there around
the club
at the senior executive level yes that I
felt betrayed
and you think they're trying to get rid
of you honestly I shouldn't say that I
don't know but listen I I don't care I'm
always people should listen the truth
yes I feel betrayed and I felt that some
people that don't want me here not only
this year but last year too
well already the interviews deeply
divided opinion uh amongst fans and
wider football supporters the club has
released a statement today saying it
will consider its response when the full
facts have been established which I take
to mean after they've watched the whole
interview but Ronaldo makes clear
throughout our conversation the Jersey
utmost respect for Manchester United's
history is a club and for its supporters
he's as frustrated about the stagnation
of the once biggest football team in the
world as they are that's why he's
speaking out because as he sees it the
club hasn't moved forward at all since
he left 13 years ago
I don't know what's going on but since
since the saralex Ferguson left I saw
not evolution in the club the progress
was Zero
for example you have a interesting point
that how the club as Manchester United
after suck
um Ole they buy they bring sport
directive Ralph ragnik which is
something that nobody understands this
guy is not even a coach
a bigger club like Manchester United
bring sport directive surprise not only
me but all the worlds you know nothing
changed surprisingly not all only the
pool the jacuzzi even the gym
even some points of Technology the
kitchen
the chefs which is I appreciate lovely
lovely persons they stop in a in a time
which is his
it surprised me a lot I thought I will
see different things different as I
mentioned before technology
infrastructure but unfortunately we see
many
things that I'm used to seeing when I
was 20 21 23 so surprised me a lot
I suppose a lot of people there are more
home trees where that came from and
sometimes let's be honest the truth can
hurt nothing was off limits in this
interview no tough questions were pulled
Ronaldo answers them all with a brutal
honesty very seldom seen from a star of
his Renown he also opens up about the
family tragedy which befell him earlier
this year in which his partner lost one
of the two twins that she was expecting
and he talks about the disrespective
fields that he's been shown by United's
manager Eric ten hark he talks about the
glazers United's unpopular American
owners and he talks honestly about
criticism of him by his former
colleagues in the old United dressing
room A lot's already been written and
said about this interview just based on
the small amount we've already revealed
a lot of it I have to say is
ill-informed bile a lot of it is just
plain fake news the only way you'll find
out what Ronaldo really says is by
watching the whole interview here on
Wednesday and Thursday and I think he'll
change a lot of people's minds when they
do
which would be now is the former
professional footballer turned pundit
Graham's soonest and two football rights
at the Times Henry Winter well welcome
to both of you so Henry uh given that
I've just spent uh 10 minutes promoting
my interview with Cristiano Ronaldo uh I
think it's only fair to balance it out
by saying that you've written a very
excoriating column as is you'll want
sometimes when you disapprove of
something about this today you think
it's a big mistake by Cristiano to do
this why
well first congratulations it's a great
scoop here's hi Graham I think I'm just
reflecting the views of probably the
majority of Manchester United fans that
this legend of the game as you say is
certainly one of the greatest probably
top five players of all time it's
slightly tarnishing his reputation in
terms of uh
in terms of how he's presented himself
and he really should have left in the
summer I think there from what I've read
so far and what I've heard and seen in
your Clips appears you know there's
there are elements of him making
pertinent points particularly about the
uh the lack of Investments it seems in
parts of Carrington and Old Trafford as
well so those are important things that
he's saying there and he is the
Statesman of the game and he should be
listened to so I think it's you know
it's an important interview but I just
think the timing of it coming the day
after Manchester United had a really
gutsy win at Fulham a young kid comes on
gun that shows the future of the club
and I just think talking to fans and I'm
sure ex-players will will Echo this is
that you have to respect the manager
he's and I think actually ten Hogg has
been pretty respectful because anyone
who's seen Ronaldo play this season he's
37 he's played I think 520 minutes in
the the Premier League one goal no
assist look he's been a fabulous player
for Manchester United Real Madrid and
clearly still with Portugal but he's not
the force that he was and ten Haag new
manager New Era okay
okay I'm soon as I want to play a clip
to both of you which is a new clip from
the interview which I think may just
give a little bit more insight into why
Cristiano Ronaldo feels quite so
disrespected by people that are running
Manchester United right now and I'll
tell you the background to this is there
was a huge Fury as you know Henry about
him not coming back to Manchester United
in the pre-season when he should have
done a lot of speculation that it was to
do with him wanting to leave the club
and get away and everything else in fact
as he reveals to me in the interview it
was because his little daughter Bella
three months old at the time who had
survived this terrible tragedy in which
uh her twin brother had died she got
bronchitis so bad that she was in
hospital for a week and he felt Duty
bound as a father I'm sure we'd all
understand this to stay with her I want
to play the clip and then just see
whether this perhaps slightly changes
your mind let's watch the clip
you lost your baby son and now your baby
daughter's in hospital exactly and you
must have been absolutely directive of
and the president of uh Manchester
United and then
kind of that didn't believe
that something going wrong which is make
me feel bad really yes I am yes I didn't
believe you
they believe you but in the same way
they are there and never this ever gonna
change
the health of my family
for a football never
now or
10 years
behind or forwards and it's something
that really hurt me because they doubt
of my words that I struggle especially
Bell and Jill we had one week in
hospital because the Bell have a big
problem
and I didn't go to the preseason because
of that because I didn't I didn't
was allowed to left my family if
something happened
to do the Precision because I think it
wasn't not fair to left my family for a
pre-season this is why I didn't go
now when he said that to me Henry I have
to say I was pretty shocked and
obviously I've not been able to put this
to Manchester United I don't know
exactly who he you know spoke to who
didn't believe him but the whole concept
that anyone a senior level at Manchester
United doubting Cristiano Ronaldo's word
about his three-month-old baby given
what had happened to his family three
months before I find pretty shocking
actually and it's unsurprising to me
that that led to the breakdown in the
relationship
there were clearly two narratives going
on in pre-season one of them as
Christiana who is very emotionally
articulated there and anyone with any
children will absolutely empathize with
him and his support for his partner and
for his children and for his daughter I
think everyone totally understands that
and if Manchester United had not shown
him the the warmth the love that he was
expecting then you know clearly they
were wrong with that my experience of
Manchester United and the staff at
Carrington and Old Trafford football and
otherwise is that she's not a cold Club
he's actually pretty warm Club there's a
lot of good people there who will look
out for a player like Cristiano who
obviously many of them got to know when
he was a kid himself at uh 18. the other
Narrative of course was always the
debate about his future and whether he
should actually continue with the
manager like ten harks so I think really
he should have gone in the summer anyway
but clearly everyone has sympathy for
you know the family predicament he had
at the time okay let me bring Graham in
Graham you've been a one of the great
players this country has ever seen a
terrific manager as well you've been on
both sides of of this fence and I
listened to you this morning on
talksport very interesting stories you
were telling about your time at
Liverpool and when similar things had
happened to you and how you reacted and
felt what do you make of of all this
what's Cristiano Ronaldo entitled to
come out and have this say in this
interview with me well that Revelation
that we've just we've just watched
United will come out and deny it they
have to they're not shown compassion
that are such a terrible time for not
believing him Ronaldo's daughter was in
hospital they have to come out and deny
that I mean my take on that whenever I
was
um managing I will leave entirely up to
the individual if
if they were having a if their family
were having a baby if he's if their
wives were having a baby
um so I'll leave it until you take as
much time as you need or if there's an
illness in the family take as much time
as you do we'll see you when when we see
you so I'm sure United will come out
tonight they will have another side to
that story
um I I get Ronaldo's argument I am
I think as much as people think they
shouldn't cut on some slack Ronaldo has
a standing in the game which is quite
unique there is he the best player
there's been there's a real argument for
him I mean I personally think it's him
or missing his stats would suggested
seven in fact he's done it in different
leagues would um goodness favor as well
um but there's no doubt about it he can
sit in the room with anyone that's ever
played football and said you know what I
think the best that's ever played and
there's a real argument does that give
you no no it doesn't I know what you're
going to say does it give you any
special entitlement I think it has to I
think it has to I think Ronaldo still
have some he still has so much to offer
not just in the playing stairs but what
it gives you in the dressing room I
consistently say appears that you have
no chance of being successful unless you
have good senior Pros right he's a
consummate yeah
I sat with him for nearly two hours he's
still got this hunger burning inside him
to win more big trophies to break more
records to be more successful and what
he really craves is an environment
around him that can enable all that to
happen and he feels he just hasn't got
that at United and a lot of it he said
it's down to poor structure and
management of the club is spot on I mean
this is not whenever I talk about United
the United supporters are up in arms
what do you expect from someone who
played in managed Liverpool but I think
United have been mismanaged to further
up the tree I think they've consistently
got the football decisions wrong and
that's why they find themselves in this
dilemma I think um getting back to
Ronaldo I think Ronaldo
when he came along I was all for it and
I when he came back yeah when he came
back I mean
there was nobody in that dressing room
there was nobody in that dressing room
the younger players would have got to
and say I want to be like him in 10
years time
he was he was the ultimate Pro you could
have gotten to correct that 18 goals
last year in the Premier League I think
it was that one more one more than a
hurricane yeah that that in itself so
you he is that good that's special you
come up with a system to suit him what I
believe this happened this is my belief
so
without venturing into what we just
witnessed with with the you know these
tragedies and the baby dying and another
baby becoming ill
um that you have to come some slack look
I'm sure there's United will have a
different story but I believe when he
says
he wants to leave there was a meeting at
the start of the Season there's a
meeting would have taken place between
the manager and Cristiano after that
meeting they both left the room with an
understanding that's going to work
United start the season losing to
Brighton and then losing to Brentford
badly I think at that moment I think the
manager and the coaching staff thought
we cannot
go down the road of using Ronaldo there
was a feeling that maybe he couldn't do
the hard yards so from that point on I
think Cristiano
would have realized that he's been
around the block many many times
um so basically Ronaldo will feel right
now that he's been told a story someone
is not not kept her word which is a
manager
and I don't know if you've ever had a
moment grandma and I I had a moment
rather famously last year when I had a
little falling out with my employers and
I felt I was being disrespected by
people I work with and I did this
and I to be honest don't regret doing
that at all
um so I kind of get uh let me go back to
Henry for a moment I kind of get that if
you feel if you're Ronaldo one of the
great players to ever play the game and
you feel disrespected professionally in
terms of what is happening on the pitch
and the way you're being used being
benched being dropped being publicly
scolded you know the mixed messaging of
uh ten Hogg not bringing him on against
Manchester City when they've got a
thumping and saying he did it out of
respect for Ronaldo and then literally a
week later trying to bring him on with
three minutes left when they're winning
tuna against Tottenham apparently
showing the complete opposite attitude
if you if you feel there's been this
build up of all this kind of
disrespectful stuff towards you and you
have in the background this awful
personal stuff going on as well and you
feel that the club has even doubted your
word about some of that I can see how
we've reached this point where he feels
enough and has come out all guns blazing
the truth in football is always out
there on the pitch and Graham as a
former manager and a former player and
he makes a very pertinent point that ten
Hart the new coach clearly felt that
Ronaldo couldn't put in to use Graham's
for he's very apt phrase he couldn't put
in the hard yards on the pitch and the
Premier League particularly is such a
grueling assignment now it's just all
about stamina it's all about pressing
and with respect to one of the greatest
players who's ever played Ronaldo at 37
wasn't going to be doing the the
pressing that was required he's
obviously he's clearly a superior player
to rashford but rashford would run
himself into the ground for the team so
I think look there are other issues
there I think not coming off the bench
when he was asked to I mean Graham's
been in the dressing room I don't know
how Graham would have reacted if any of
his Liverpool players have refused to to
come off the bench and then going down
the tunnel and this element that it's
all about me well in fact well he does
he does say to me yeah look he's
completely embodied in his Liverpool
teams that it's all about it should all
be about the team yeah I know I just
think Ronaldo's about the team but I
think but also the fact that yeah I do
think Ronaldo he believes his own
personal goals and Excellence as a
footballer helps the team he thinks the
two go hand in hand he did say to me he
did apologize to all his teammates and
shouldn't have done what he did at
Tottenham but he also Graham he also
said that he just felt this ongoing
disrespect from his coach both about
personal stuff and professional and he
just said it just it boiled over I think
it's down to him not him changing his
mind from the two this is what I believe
the two losses Brentford and Brighton
and then at that point he has to sit
down with him again and say look this is
what I'm thinking I think it just boils
down and it's to his credit Ronaldo
wants to play every minute of every game
right he still sees himself as a winner
he he will be a realist as well he'll
realize he can't do the running down the
channels he actually admits that he
admits that in the interview he says
he's not the player he was but he thinks
he's a smarter player than he used to
and Henry memory references Russian
there's no comparison you know because
your stats say that you're on whatever
kilometers around how many miles it's
it's the end product the hardest thing
in football is to score goals it does
that better than anyone that United has
I mean I I if I've been managing them I
I think you have to come up with a
United are not in a place right now
where
they want to be that's the plightest
thing I can see well they're fifth in
the league the 13 points they're in the
playoffs for the Europa League I mean
this is not a place United uh used to be
take take 18 goals out of United Seasons
last year that could have been in the
relegations where's the Finish yeah
there are still there's still room for
United sorry for Ronaldo United and I
think this whole Saga has been it's it's
been handled so badly it was it was
avoidable
um I think with better communication
with people telling the truth
and and I think that's where Ronaldo's
beef is I think he's been told in
untruth can you stay there now I don't
think he can I think all the bridges are
burnt now Henry is there any way back
for Cristiano even if you wanted to come
back
no chance and particularly the timing of
your your very good interview peers the
timing of it shortly after the final
Premier League game of the first half of
the Season there's no Ray Ronaldo could
have your interview could have gone out
a week ago because if he'd had to step
out in front of the Manchester United
fans fans who for so many years sang
Viva Ronaldo he would very sadly have
got a different reception
Portugal had a good run in the whole
time Ronaldo fans right but if Portugal
have a good run in the World Cup they've
got a good team and Ronaldo starts
banging in goals in the World Cup I mean
in the end great players hold a lot of
love fantastic you see we're upset
fantastic but he's 37 he's not the
player he was
still got a lot to offer Henry you know
if you go back to Aguero City where he
wouldn't be deemed to have been the best
during the hard yards the closing down
The Unwanted stuff Strikers don't really
enjoy it
he would get away with it you United
should have looked at the situation but
Manchester United have got a new manager
and a new era and ten hog was always
going to be Manchester United
was very much their past and he should
have gone in the summer we're obsessed
this this whole situation has been
handed handled very badly by United in
my opinion he is a player issue kept on
site he is
a player that's something that you're
still us
I think I'll have a lot to offer a
football club for me they've just
they've handled it very poorly how do
you how do you how do you think it was
going to end when you're upsetting a
player of a standing I think that's the
problem we're talking about this instead
of United on the front foot moving
forward winning a difficult game I also
think I also think to be fair to
Cristiano that you've got to watch the
whole interview all people have seen so
far are a few Clips literally there's
like two or three Clips it's it's a long
90 minute plus interview we're gonna air
over two days if you watch it all and
you come to the same conclusion Henry
has fair enough uh but I think a lot
more people will feel sympathetic
towards Ronaldo by the end of it than
they might be feeling at the moment I
gotta leave it there Henry thank you
very much indeed for joining us Graham
great to have you on the show pleasure
for coming in really appreciate it
we're coming next accused of hurling an
egg at the king Patrick delwell says his
arrest was the most rewarding experience
of his life which just suggests to me
he's had a very very strange life
we'll talk to him live
he Russell took her own life after
viewing online content about self-harm
Molly's father Ian says he delays were
Bill supposed to crack down on harmful
content could cost young lives he's
putting on the government to get their
act together he'll be with me next
foreign
[Music]
see you tomorrow morning love you was
the last thing that Ian Russell said to
His Daughter Molly
Molly was 14 when she took her own life
she was suffering from depression and
had been reading posts about self-harm
online in September a coroner ruled
social media had contributed more than
minimally to her death and her father
described the content that Molly viewed
as demented and life-sucking and
believes that she hadn't seen those
posts she might still be alive today and
Ian Russell joins me now Ian thank you
so much for coming in I've written about
this I've invested a lot of time
researching this and as a father of a
young girl myself my heart absolutely
goes out to you for what you and your
family have had to endure here and I'm
so grateful to you for now campaigning
to try and stop it happening to other
young girls because this is a deadly
rabbit Warren the internet and in
particular these social media sites like
Instagram and Pinterest which I know
Molly was using regularly because these
algorithms drive this darker and darker
material
into their impressionable young minds to
as we see deadly conclusion that's
absolutely true we couldn't work out
what happened to Molly why that happened
to Molly she was such a positive
forward-looking girl
um it was a mystery to us so it wasn't
long before we started to look into her
social media accounts and what we found
there shocked us horrified this was
after she died she died we looked at
some of the posts that she'd seen and
saved and liked and what kind of thing
was it for people who don't know about
this well that's the problem in terms of
telling this story is on broadcast
channels like this you're not allowed to
to show those so isn't that
extraordinary so I we couldn't show this
stuff because it's deemed to be so
damaging and yet social media up it goes
all the time and is deliberately
targeted through the these algorithms
right so there was research that
Samaritans published last week they did
some research in conjunction with the
University of Swansea over three
quarters of
um young teenagers said that they'd seen
um self-harm content online by the time
they they were 14 that's three quarters
of young it's absolutely shocking and
what's worse is 83 percent of those
people said that they didn't search for
that content it was the platform's
algorithms that pushed that content
towards them when you discovered all
this stuff after Molly died and clearly
you then got the answers to all of the
questions that you must have been asking
yourself is that how could this possibly
have happened to our girl and yet there
it is clear this is what happened to her
her brain was almost sort of deranged by
this
filth that was coming down the line from
these social media companies you then
decided right I'm going to try and be
active in getting something done tell me
about what it is that you're
specifically trying to do
it's really to raise awareness to make
change happen because the the tech
bosses at these platforms have had it
easy up until now they've had it easy
their companies have been growing until
this making us a fortune making billions
of pounds in profits and their whole aim
has been to to keep those profits going
as best possible and keep people on
their platforms and they've prioritized
profits and they haven't designed safety
into those products or given much
thoughts about how their users should be
safe online the game-changing moment
came when this coroner actually directly
linked Molly's death to what the social
media content not exclusively but
certainly said it was a big contributory
Factor has there been any kind of sea
change since this verdict that you've
identified
um no the coroner also issued a
prevention of future deaths report which
means he's given the platforms and the
government for that matter 56 days to
come back and say what they're going to
do in order to try and stop such deaths
occurring again have any of these
Platformers contacted you personally
there's been very limited content
contact while the inquest has been going
on but we will see what happens when
they when they come back at the end of
that 56 day period 8th of December
they've got until to come up with some
ways of making their their platforms
safer particularly for young children
what is happening with the online arms
bill which we've read a lot about but
seems to be like almost everything in
the government at the moment because of
the chaos sort of stuck in limbo land is
there any real movement with it so the
Online safety bill is is now code it was
called the online homes bill but it's
it's called The Online safety bill
um should have had its third reading in
the Commons in July which means it would
be in the Lord so now I'm being
scrutinized by peers and then it could
it could would go on to become law and
of course standing in the wings ready to
be the regulator but that didn't happen
because of the political turmoil and it
it was then to have its third reading on
the first of November same thing
happened again and along with lots of
other bits of governmental uh
legislation and and uh
um procedures that happen in Parliament
it's it's stopped but there does seem to
be
um a commitment I had a a text today
from the coach secretary Michelle Donald
um saying know that the Online safety
bill has dragged just wanted to reassure
you that both I and the Prime Minister
are personally committed to getting it
completed this session that you got that
personally today from from Michelle
Darwin what did you feel when you read
that well that's good because nothing's
going to happen uh because the the tech
platforms have been self-regulating and
that hasn't been good enough so
nothing's going to happen until
governments regulate that's the first
step but the proof of the pudding is
what's in that bill because what do you
want to see in it what has to happen is
that things that are illegal in the
offline World in our world are also
clearly illegal and and controllable
yeah uh and the and the regulator can do
something about it in the in the online
world but also the stuff that Molly did
see and I can quote an example she saw
for example a little cartoon drawing of
a sad look looking girl that simply said
who would love a suicidal girl now that
foreign on its own isn't too harmful
maybe isn't too dangerous but when
you're
seeing posts like that in the hundreds
or maybe even I think it is dangerous
even well you've just told me shocks me
the idea that a young girl could be
viewing that kind of thing
when their brains aren't really fully
formed they're not properly 14 is a
tough time for me yes it's extremely
tough really tough time and that content
was pushed to Molly by the algorithms
and so that content which is harmful but
may be considered to be legal also has
to be regulated against because if if
the regulator doesn't have the powers to
remove that content then sadly there may
be more tragedies like mollies what can
parents who are watching this and share
the horror I'm probably I'm feeling
about this what can they do
to better protect their kids in the
meantime
that's a really difficult type rope to
walk you've basically got to keep a
dialogue going I think between you and
your children it's really hard to do
that if you push too hard they can find
ways to show you the fluffy toys and the
celebrities whilst on another account
maybe having the content that they don't
want you to see in fact for example we
all followed each other as a family on
Twitter Molly didn't seem to be a social
media person she deleted her Twitter
account because she didn't use it what
we didn't know until the inquest was
she'd set up a secret Twitter account so
it's a very difficult balancing app but
all I would say is keep that dialogue
going talk about the problems that you
might find online and encourage people
young people in your family to tell
their parents about it finally tell me
about Molly just quickly what kind of
girl she was she was the most gorgeous
of girl one of the most caring
individuals uh I've ever known she loved
helping others she loved making people
off as well she had a keen sense of
humor and whatever she would have done
with her life we have no doubt that it
would have been fascinating and amazing
and sadly we'll never know what that
would have been
I'm so sorry for your loss for you and
your family I can't think of anything
worse and the way that she was almost
steered to her death by social media
platforms is an absolute disgrace and
we'll certainly do whatever we can on
the show to to keep this in the
Limelight until proper definitive action
is done to protect other girls thank you
peers thank you for coming in thank you
well still to come he's accused of
throwing an egg at the new king and he
says he's been banned from carrying eggs
in public and he's smoking away in our
camera tonight Patrick delwell will be
here live after the break
and the direction to the man who puts
the [ __ ] into Hancock
because he actually end up winning
people around we'll debate that after
the break as well
[Music]
this is talk TV
[Music]
talk about joining me and now is
tonight's Superstar pack totally
contributor Emily Sheffield political
journalist Ava Santina Associated to the
Daily Mirror Kevin McGuire who I last
saw this morning on Good Morning Britain
actually looking at clips of me and Matt
Hancock absolutely
which was quite entertaining because it
was all about this I mean obviously the
the [ __ ] in Hancock continues um it was
quite interesting they were debating the
fact that in I'm a celebrity he talked
about how he avoided answering questions
I think we've got a clip of this the
pivot in in politics is called the pivot
and you oh right so you have to you have
to you have to uh you have to control
give enough link to the question that it
doesn't look like you're avoiding the
question whilst pivoting and a good
pivot is admirable
that just confirms everything I've
always thought about this slippery toad
so this is a good morning brick this
morning actually brought me back from
the dead to show exactly what he means
by the pivot watch this
my question to you is will you be taking
a pay cut as you urge footballers to do
and as the government in New Zealand is
doing yes or no well I'm not proposing
to do that what I am proposing to do is
work every hour that there is do you
support the boycott did you agree with
it well I'm I'm here to answer all of
the questions that you might have on
behalf of your viewers I just asked you
one um I was
I mean what a slippery little toad of
the type that's running after him in the
Australian bush I'm sorry to keep
harping on about this but I don't get
the joke with Hancock I don't think any
of this is funny I don't think him
deserting his constituency flying around
the world 400 Grand in the back pocket
in a cost of living crisis trading off
his infamy for horrendous handling of
the the first wave of the pandemic and
then the scandal of him having to quit
for breaking his own lockdown rules what
is funny about this and why are these
people in the jungle now high-fiving him
and cheering let's take a look at last
night
program
do you know what it is actually oh
what I'm really looking for is a bit of
forgiveness
[Music]
oh it's only small it's only small okay
oh okay it hurts a lot and I'm feeling
slightly dizzy this is a mistake because
I've fell in love with somebody and
yeah
what is true what I do sorry I'm
literally puking I'm puking I can't
watch any of this I fell in love so shut
up Hancock now before we get to the the
Superstar pack I just want to make a
revelation about tomorrow night's show
is it because Matt Hancock has deserted
his constituents I'm going to take the
show to his local pub which is the [ __ ]
in it's actually called the [ __ ] in it's
in uh West Suffolk and we're going to
take the whole show down there I'm going
to broadcast from inside the [ __ ] in
about the man who puts the [ __ ] into
Hancock and I'm actually gonna have an
obvious constituents there who are
absolutely raging with Fury about him
deserting them at this very difficult
time so tomorrow night live from the
[ __ ] in uh in in West Suffolk we have
got a picture but rather like Hancock in
the jungle it's uh it's all gone to
Helena Hancock trying to find it let me
ask you Kevin
let me ask you Kevin
why is this funny any of this because
when we go down tomorrow night I can bet
your life a lot of these constituents
will be raging about him oh they will
and uh deservedly so look he gets 84
Grand a year and he's uh he's gone up to
get a 400 Grand paycheck and reinvent
himself there's nothing funny about it
at all he's an act he's a fraud that's
what he is and he he's winning some of
the other campers over because it's
almost like the Stockholm syndrome being
with your captors and you begin to like
it right I mean I'm worried about the
health of the Scorpion have you got any
updates well these poor animals having
to bite into his flesh but it's all it's
such a fake attempt to rebuild his PR
and it's like I said sorry no too soon
where's the inquiry into the pandemic
first yeah I mean if he cared even an
inch he'd be there at the Forefront of
the inquiry properly apologizing laying
out all of the evidence what he did
throughout the pandemic and really
owning up to it going in here and eating
some eyeballs is not gonna Not Gonna
Change anyone's opinion at all no but
also there's a serious point I mean he's
paid
he's a paid Member of Parliament he's
only 85 000 pounds a year to actually
serve his country as a an MP in his
constituency shouldn't be left to me to
go and hold his surgery in his
constituency I'm very happy to do it and
I'm sure it'll be very Lively television
but this should not be happening but I
think it's very hard to defend uh Matt
Hancock at the moment so but I'm going
to semi-child someone's got to is I
think he's not uh it was in recess so
he's probably at Max going to miss 10
days in his constituency he is online
with them and talking to them I think
it's more no he's not yes he is he had
that agreement tonight his constituency
office has been sending back out of
office saying we'll come back to this
later that's how they are he he'd gone
on we promise like everything I'll tell
you when the pinch is that he claimed
that he would be I do think there is an
opportunity I think it that he could he
is reaching a very large audience now
put aside the fact that we all probably
agree this was a pay the money be a sort
of career switch there is a very real
opportunity for him to talk
to millions of viewers about political
life and what happened during the
pandemic and actually face up the anger
yeah
for love well yes but fine but then the
campers the campers I think could or
could be giving him a lot harder time
for it that is what I find is quite
surprising surprising they've all
they've all eaten the jungle Kool-Aid
right now they're all like oh he's a
hero he's putting his hand into a bowl
of snakes and he's coming back with
little stars and I'm like through none
of this is making me laugh yeah but I
remember what happened you also hear Boy
George and Mike Tindall and Sue Cleaver
as it's Corey yeah plotting against him
others having some complaints I think
let's see how we plan see how it pans
out but it's all about him he's not
doing it for democracy or greater
politics explaining Westminster you're
certainly not doing it
which he hasn't mentioned so far from
what well unless that's been edited out
and I do think that's a shame he's not
well you think you think we are on the
hour mentioning well he doesn't have
control about what goes out remember so
I do think it's a shame because dyslexia
is a really serious problem and leads to
a lot of young people all right well
we're going to be down at the [ __ ] uh in
West Suffolk tomorrow which is a
brilliant idea myself
the appropriately named we have a little
bit of VoiceOver live from the [ __ ] in
foreign
little little furlough in West Suffolk
that's the [ __ ] in it's the famous pub
where his mate ran the
pube contract the new owner is not such
a friend oh such a fan hence we're going
to be in there
um fun to just talk quickly about
Ronaldo obviously I would say this I've
done the interview but I think he's
entitled to have his say I think he's
been pretty pretty appallingly and
actually anyone should be entitled to
their say yeah I'm delighted he's had
his say look he's one of the world's
greatest footballers and I'm sick and
tired as a football fight
a solid fan I've been told of a player's
not playing or there's something it's
they're real or they're really loud yeah
and you know you know it's a lie I mean
they've fallen out big time he feels
badly triggered now whether he was or
not you'd need the other side of the
argument to decide but he feels badly
treated I mean Heavenly the shocking
thing is the new clip we played tonight
where if this is true and I don't doubt
him at all and in fact it's ironic given
what the clip is that having lost his
baby's son that three months later his
baby girl who survived they were twins
get seriously ill with bronchitis
hospitalized for a week he's worried
sick obviously with his girlfriend
Georgina and so he decides to stay with
the family rather than go on the
pre-season friendly tour and the club
don't even believe him by his account I
mean if that is if that's correct
um and I guess we need to hear the club
come back on this or even I have to say
if they allowed Ronaldo to think that
means they didn't handle it right yeah
he had lost a child that is three months
later this cut this this that kind of
grief lasts a very long time and if you
suddenly when you lose one child I can
say from some experience in my own
family is that you become very panicked
about the health of the others
absolutely Ava any thoughts on Chris
January I just think he came across as a
really desperate man I think it was
really sad to watch it's like it's a
difficult watch I don't think he's
desperate I think he's very frustrated
yes by the sequence of events on and off
the pitch and I certainly think and I
would because I'm doing so good on
censored he's allowed to have his
opinion stay with me back because we're
about to talk exclusively for his first
television interview to the young man
who threw an a at New King Charles and
I'll ask him why he did it
there he is oh yeah
everyone's had their say about the
world's most famous footballer now it's
his turn
start by asking why are you doing this
interview I think it's the time
to say something 90 minutes for
Cristiano Ronaldo
an exclusive that's rocked the sports
world
Wednesday and Thursday nights at 8pm
only on Piers Morgan uncensored
[Music]
well he's accused of egging uh King
Charles while shouting this country was
built on the blood of slaves he's had
death threats but he says the arrest was
the most rewarding and worthwhile
experience of his life and Patrick
felwald joins me now and Mr thorwell
thank you for joining me why did you
throw an egg at King Charles
uh allegedly uh
an egg at the king
you did it all right sorry peers I came
on the show with the understanding that
that you knew that I can't discuss the
ins and outs I know making Charles King
Charles one of the Walker back in York
on the understanding no idiot with throw
negative so we've all been well
interested I was arrested we've all been
let down you you rescued yourself we've
been let down by the monarchy by the
rulers of this country yeah uh the
reason why I don't believe in the
monarchy is because I think that all
people are equal and therefore I don't
think anyone's blood is any more special
than others uh and we're living in a
cost of living crisis at the moment
where some people can't afford to eat so
why would you waste or to eat food and
you've got why would you waste an egg
well it's
every day
yeah
every day it's actually his birthday
today I think he's 76 today every day
the King has five eggs boiled for him he
picks one that's the consistency is
right on and then he throws away the
other four to be serious for a moment
today Patrick to be serious
four months ago right this is a man
who's been several months ago people
said that
wasn't the right time answer my question
why would you think that regardless of
anything to do with the monarchy why
would you think it's a decent thing to
do to a man who's still grieving the
loss of his mother the queen to just
hurl eggs at him and his wife in the
street why do you think that's a
sensible thing to be doing
so a couple of months ago when the queen
died people said that now is not the
time to protest against the monarchy
every protest that's happened in this
country over the last couple of months
you people like you have disagreed with
the methods they've disagreed with the
Target and I'm telling you now that
there is no one who is a more worthy
Target for people in this country who
are angry at the poverty that they're
being forced to live in whilst he gets
to wear a crown of stolen jewels and
live in a palace
you protest everything don't you you're
a Serial activist and protester you've
been arrested five times wrong with the
world you're always you're out there
with your little legs bag and you're
throwing them everyone right
if you say so Fizz I just think honestly
I think you're a total dick
[Music]
okay so is swearing okay on this show or
not absolutely wrong but unfortunately
there's no time thanks Patrick
um so uh that's Patrick bellwell he was
about to obviously unleash the verbal
version of his egg throwing um chucking
an egg at King Charles it's pathetic
isn't it yeah look I'm a republican uh
I'm against the monarchy but I just
think it's it's definitely respect it's
uh the man's 76 today with his wife it
would have been a scary incident right
he's still mourning his mother for the
love of God just show them answers
it just doesn't win anyone in your
argument no I mean that's it as a
republican I want argument over any
defense for this idiot look it's
impossible to win the argument with the
monarchy I'm not gonna Park Park the egg
throwing because I'm not into the EXO
ring but he has got a point he does get
five eggs balls from every morning he
does live a life of luxury and you're
not allowed to doesn't everybody get
five eggs boil for them in the morning
Emily are you defending in this imbecile
I've noticed because I I don't really
understand what his message is I mean
all you just end up hearing is you hear
about it
no no
sucking eggs around the cost of living
crisis
hits them with an egg you'll be whingy
well talking of eggs will be down at the
talking uh in West Suffolk tomorrow go
down if you want to join the party we'll
be doing what Matt Hancock should be
doing that's it for tonight Keep It
Uncensored good night
[Music]